there's a discussion of people stepping
up now using the hashtag me too
what are your thoughts do you think this
is a floodgate that needed to be open a
long time ago are you happy what's
happening now
yeah it should have happened a long time
ago and i'm happy it's happening now
i was so lucky i have to say i got
signed when i was 19
and i got in with a bunch of guys who
weren't sexist
and never gave me any indication that i
should dress a certain way
or put my hair a certain way they just
let me be who i was
and so i sort of went along with this
you know
naive notion that that was how the world
worked
[Music]
every generation it gets a little bit
better and we have the luck of geography
too being born in canada
the rights of women are so much further
ahead than in most countries talking to
my girls
i do tend to harp sometimes about you
know i hope you realize how good you
have it
when you start complaining about
something i you know i say the first
world problem sing a lot but also just
like
do you understand there's so many women
in the world
who don't get to go to school oh i love
that i wouldn't want to go to school
you know what honey you do want to go to
school because you want to be educated
education is power
sarah keeps her two daughters age 10 and
15 completely out of the public eye
my 15 year old bless her she's well
she's always been challenging the boy
she's
really pushing the buttons these days
yeah pushing the boundaries at it
that is her job as a 15 year old how do
you keep them grounded
i try really hard not to judge them i
try to keep my mouth shut
because you'll you'll get way more as
soon as you start judging or saying
anything about
who are you hanging out with that person
it's like they'll never talk to you
about it again
sarah says she got some of her parental
guidance from her own mother
but not the way you think she taught me
how not to be
she was extremely harsh and a very hard
woman she was
clinically depressed and she was very
much you
all you'll fail don't think you're
anything special you're never going to
amount to anything
and so for me that was that was the
impetus to prove her wrong
it also made me incredibly incredibly
compassionate
for people like i'm very empathetic and
i think because she was incapable of
that and i don't i think it's maybe just
in my dna as well i'm just very
different than her i'm adopted as well
but i had music yeah and it was such
a positive joyful outlet for me
[Music]
these days sarah is using that voice to
help charities like
war child whose gala event i recently
hosted and where sarah performed
it's so easy for me to show up for one
night sing a couple songs
and be part of an event that's so
powerful it's fun it feels good
it feels good feels like i'm using my
tools like i'm using my power
for creating positive social change but
zero's also taking time for some more
leisurely activities
and not so leisurely now you surf
i do that's pretty sure if it wakes i
started wake surfing this summer i don't
know what that is but it's behind a boat
no way so they wait the boat creates
this little wake and you get up there
and it's
great at the back of a boat you've got
this beautiful wake that just goes and
goes and goes and you have so much time
to practice your form and
yeah so i got a lot better